and also online i do
n't know how many people might be watching the stream
but a very warm
welcome we are pleased that you are all
here and would like to discuss sustainable mobility with us today
and for the online participants
there is the possibility of this
online  -tool slider to discuss with
if you enter the
url sli dot of the eu in a browser of your
choice you then have
to enter this code this is the
zip code of the natural history museum 10115
then you come to the questions in our
event
and then we start we are  here in
or excuse me
start a little preliminary remark as
you will see filmed if someone from
the local participants absolutely does not want to
appear in this film who will
also be cut into bits and pieces to be found
on the internet afterwards
please give us a short show of hands that we
know that
again  in the direction does not film
that does not look like a
thank you very much and then i would also like to thank the
organizations that can be seen here in the logo
on the screen, the
free university berlin, the
observing institute berlin and the arizona state
university have all
somehow contributed to the fact that this
event can take place here in a
very special way  we would like to thank the global
summit forum without this
between the fourth as
you will see here today and the
excellence cluster marketplace this is the
berlin research center for
mathematics that supports the event here today
we are in the natural
history museum in the polar bear glory and the iceberg  the one
sitting there is often used as a
symbol to point out the dangers of
climate change,
so let's first take a look at
the emission targets from the German
climate protection law,
it's about the amount of emissions
from 1990 to last year, initially
around 40  percent to
reduce by 65% by 2030 and then m  With further
intermediate steps, climate neutrality is to be achieved by 2045.
If we look at the data
that we have had on emissions in Germany so far
, then
this curve here moves roughly around this line
around the target, but if
we put the trend in there then we will see
that it still has to get a whole
lot steeper in order to achieve the goals in the future
and
in particular the transport sector is a problem child
because
nothing has happened yet an emission reduction
the curve is simply pretty flat
if you look at a study by the Federal Environment
Agency
traffic turnaround for everyone
then look at it is
not just the emissions and thus the
lack of generational justice a
problem in today's mobility system
but also social justice
today this is just an example picture from
this study because we see that of the
households with very low income
over 50  percent not at all a  car
ownership, on the other hand, among households with a
very high income,
50 percent even own two or more
cars these are figures for the whole of
germany
if we look at berlin,
the car law looks a bit different than the
average
in germany there are more than 500 in all of germany
cars per 1000 inhabitants the mobilized
researcher andreas knee once said so nicely
we can put the whole republic in
the cars and nobody has to be in
the back seat in berlin a
few have to be in the back seat there are figures
from the beginning of 2009 10,335 cars per
1000 inhabitants but here too the
trend is rising of
course there are not only cars in
mobility this is a so-called mode so
there is the distribution of the routes to
the different means of transport
we see that 30 percent of the routes
are made on foot 18 percent with the
bicycle and
motorized individual transport for
this mgv here stands
26 or the pnv 27 per cent  ent,
however, we count the individual
routes and do not pay attention to whether a route is
perhaps shorter or longer if
we were to distribute the whole thing according to the kilometers
then the picture would of course
look different the
footpaths tend to be shorter than distances
covered by car  and with
kilometers you would still have exactly 5
percent pedestrians and
over 40 percent drivers, i.e. or
kilometers driven by car
the
swedish professor for
international health hans rosling,
who unfortunately has passed away in the meantime,
once wrote you can’t understand the world
without numbers and in this
meaning here are just a few numbers a
small excerpt from the numbers about
mobility today rosling
also said right away you can’t understand the world
with numbers alone either
and that’s why we take it here in
or not therefore but in this sense
we take it here in  hessian fourth
just the discussion with you and
the modeling of future
events just to think about it
we saw from these numbers
that something has to change and the question
then is of course what the changes might look like
we want to
think about that together here today we have
a few more pictures as input
brought
scheer in berlin in 2035 it will
continue to look like this only that these
cars are all electrically driven
or can we
draw an input from what we see once a
year in berlin for the rally if even highways are allowed to be cycled
on by bike
we might get one  extremely
digitized technological world in
which the streets actually had to
look the same as before
and we would now like to bring your ideas
to this event we
have two microphones so if you are on
site you can just get in touch
and a microphone will be brought then
you can  namely tell us
or kö  If the
online participants are again sorry about this,
they can also contribute ideas or
questions, which we can then read out here
in the room,
yes, what are your ideas, what are your
ideas, perhaps, the
ideals, perhaps, horror
ideas of mobility in Berlin in the
year 2035 in the
future  my wish, since i
live on frankfurter allee, is that the number of cars will be
massively reduced
because we have such a mess and such
a noise there for that
reason alone but of course also from an
environmental perspective anyway
thank you very much i would also say that
fits perfectly  good to the reports we have
from the internet there is
the key word
public we have more
ideas for mobility in about 15 years
i would like us to
look at the cities where it
works well after amsterdam after
utrecht after copenhagen the actually  not
much fewer cars per inhabitant have
a  about who
have almost completely separated car traffic and bicycle traffic
,
which
makes cycling much more attractive and i'm a
big fan of cycling, not
only because it's quieter but also
because it's healthy and because it's faster if we have the
infrastructure,
thank
you very much me  I don't see any further requests to speak,
but we still have one back there.
I think we'll continue with the left-hand
scenario because I don't think the
mobility behavior of many people will
change that much.
Driving electric cars to go shopping and
it's still from one side and
elites faster with the author on the
other side and so don't change anything about
it i don't think so much either
and i don't look at the efforts at the
moment either,
that means it would take changes
in people's heads to bring about these
efforts and on the other hand
changes in the  implementation for a
mobility of the future that really
can look different and
how you can look a bit into the future
with the help of a model
we also want to look at here today
and that is why stefan fürst will now introduce us to
the mobility french model
with which you can also experiment afterwards
hello
our model water
that  you can see
that the model is based on more than just a type of modeling that has
the special feature that you have to have simple
rules, but david doesn't even have to
be that simple in the end, but in
principle teaches individual thunderstorms simple rules
, so here's an
example to see a
model with sheep and  wolves and there
is an area of grass and the green had t
e patches here are the more grass
there is at this point and l
ads to the sheep wanting to see there is just
he rule to run t
the point the most grass is prese
t and for the wolves the tempt
tion  has sheep to feed for years
and, depending on the situation, there is
also his energy cow  shalt am the
need
and depending on the consumption the sheep
stronger and 12 and you can reproduce the population genetics that you can
observe in nature
that is the this
basic idea was from agent-based
models that are really still used a lot in
biology we have use
now  however, more for a
sociological model
and have as an agent the people i.e. people
living in germany who are
thinking about
what type of mobility they want to
use for everyday mobility
and here is really no
holiday travel and it is only
local passenger transport that is motivated we do
n’t have any good modeling  transfer
and stories like that the people
have the choice between five
different types of mobility that
he is once when
driving on with an internal combustion engine once when using an electric motor in
their vehicles once when using their vehicles once
in public transport
car sharing
providers so here both floating and
also support more what now
means car sharing or
you don't move around with a motor,
so on foot or by bike
and
to make a decision about
it there are different preferences
[music]
yes swimming technique
and
there are four
different types of the  the first is
how expensive is the mobility
locomotion
that was quite easy to access the
second so
you can just calculate the prices on a ford movements
how and it goes into the model
the second gets a bit vague
that’s how
ecological traffic
is so  electric vehicle will, for example
, be opposed to the
energy mix that he just has in
germany a projection of how
the energy mix will change but how
that will change now i don’t know exactly that’s why
the third isn’t quite as easy as
mobility is innovative there are people
who would like to have it  e always use the
latest technology and we
are a bit of an innovator
. for example, my father was someone
or there are people who are more conservative
and don't change as quickly
getting around their preferences
and the fourth symbol is probably
the hardest to recognize that he is a
present pillows
and this is about the
comfort of your safe and that
is quite a difficult vague
term so it is probably still very weak
of all but
at the same time one of the most
common where i have not even
mentioned that we will have a
group discussion
afterwards and with  where you
can select ten arias and for these
scenarios this comfort is often
used to change something
or these curves
that I am now explaining here and how it
works so we
assume that what is comfortable
or not that it also depends on it  where
the person lives so if  For
example, I live in the open countryside and have longer
distances to travel and always
come or
go shopping. Riding a bike is probably
more of a problem than if you live in the
city, so comfort here depends on the population density
, a person became
lively
and here  an example of the comfort
of electric vehicles where the assumption is
in it that is actually comfortable in medium-
sized cities is a
very large city in particular this very
strong production that is no longer
so comfortable because you are often stuck in traffic
jams and
in the sparsely populated regions
this is now becoming  do it differently
the model is four years old and so
you quickly have problems that the
preparatory work is far too far that
the rescuers are finally acoustically no longer
enough and that's how we have a lot
of people put their hands in it and who has
more time to do it  model to introduce
and also present more for these
assumptions  when we can do that today
, but
try to keep it a bit
transparent
and these comfort
curves can then often be created in these scenarios
by
selecting individual actions as you hope
so
that they are adjusting screws where you can change
something, this comfort is often  curves
somehow changed that's why I'm going to go into
a bit more detail 1
as well as the actually very rest of the
model yes and basically you can see
here now the comfort for which it was
before you chose this scenario
this option becomes this
scenario and the second curve  is
then the changed the diagrams can
often be seen more often later
in the kosovo groups
but there is always one of us who
can explain it again things
are still quite unclear
but your dolls as
a whole is unfortunately the structure of
the model a bit
more complicated because
the
person
still  h once you go back
each of these people then has
different preferences they
have so we stopped
comes the entire population of
germany reduced to the fact of 50
but in principle we have
15 million agents who
witness the synthetic population that
's the technical term  it tries to
somehow integrate statistical data that we know from the microcensus or from mobility studies so that this
synthetic regulation
corresponds as far as possible to what is known from these
data sets
and it is very important because
the study mobility in germany in
the model also consists of the fact that
householders  be interviewed how they moved
on a key
date and from the people in the
households you can then get into the path
profile of a day
and we also have these households
on the model we just have the person
who meets their preferences but for
Finally, the household must decide whether
m  actually buys a car or not
that’s why there is between
per household basically yes selected
mobility type of these households are i
have already mentioned you have professional
division through the position
lights are also assigned to certain places
and there is also an external
world market whose influence plays  because, for
example, the development of
electric vehicles
also depends very much on how things look in other countries
than if china decides
to make a major switch to
electric vehicles then the technology will of course become
cheaper faster and the
price also plays a role
for us a model for  the decision
by the agents which mobility
they prefer
too well
as a result you can then have a
few different ones you can take a
look at I’ll go over it briefly and
what I’m showing here is
the so-called business as usual
scenario that’s just a projection of
how it is in  future continues these are
j  ahr 2035
in the event that from these
various options that you
can select in the scenario
kainz has been selected so
basically this time you
can select the
measures that can be taken and if you
don't do anything then that
would continue with me  but
we would also like to say clearly now
that
this is not a prediction model this
year as if
we are going to be stronger so what
differences do the measures make as if
we hit these lines exactly
we would also think that this is very
unlikely and very difficult for
such a  topic to make very good prediction model
how to use the tablet
what you can see here is that five
different types of mobility
and
in principle the developments you can see
that even the
combustion engine does not even increase here and
relatively late the first electric vehicle will
eventually prevail there is here
that is  well this dotted line
is basically that  is the goal of the
federal government, which in 2018
determined when and how many
electric vehicles should actually
be moving in Germany and
you can see that it is also
very far away but as I said it
is not a perfect forecast model that
we have but
i think it is the one  million that they are
unrealistic is also
ok with the current developments
and we can also convert that
an illusion as I said, for example
for electric vehicles we then calculate
the energy mix with certain scenarios
that are evolving for which there
is another representation that is a bit
better  basically the entire
mission is shown by
superimposing the individual missions
and here you can also see that the
emission target is missed by a long way,
which the eu had planned for me with a 30 percent reduction
.
this supposed
resolution can also have us on a map
Let's see what  is changing and as
an example the proportion of e-mobility
type that has been selected in
different households or in person
and
see that is in the case especially
in urban regions
the proportion is increasing so the
greener the area is our largest proportion
that can  also moved into
different areas, so it's that
they, for example, just Berlin
and the rest of the curves,
yes, there isn't one mistake,
ok, I have to take a look now
, so unfortunately you don't see that
much
and he they
the last government we still have
is what we know from whales as a
mistake the paper warns so here are
the five different types and on the
left is that the selection from
2017 and we know every single
agent so we know what he chose in
2035  and then was able to show, for
example, that no woman has
even decreased overall, some
have
gone over to burn from verbre  nner a bit soul electro
and
it will be exciting a comparable
scenario makes you can see
where the differences are but i
think we don't know that now
if not we still have a few minutes
before then the only
option for questions to be explained
so it's not entirely clear to the model or to the visualization yes
there is a krot
yes that's
how the
electric bikes appear so that powered
vehicles or serena yes unfortunately not at all
what if we
want to install that in our model now
yes you could think about whether to do that
it's actually worth starting your own type for this
i don't really see any other
option i think it's
actually an exciting topic because
we can see a very strong
change and actually
more energy and emissions
are caused at once by one
mobility locomotion we wo
n't
have that before i see my tatsäc  hlich so
that we would then have to integrate another type
into the model yes
type of active mobility so even
walking and cycling as a 1 concept
you could also do that, especially if
you really had to take a look at urban traffic
you would of course still have to
divide it out by  as
being able to look at different measures
i have a question about how the
differences were taken into account is
there a preference for each agent who
was born or was there a direction or how did you
do it so each your
agent has
the right value determined by these four preferences  Mathematically
, there was between zero and one how
important this preference is to him and the sum
must be 1 and
economy is there a benefit function
you can then calculate how great the
benefit is from the mobility type with
these references
i have another question about comfort
option for me as a bike rider is,
for example, that the topology of the terrain is
relatively different  right now whether it's uphill
downhill or straight how can
you read that in the
model so it's not in the model we
've actually only integrated the density for comfort, so we've actually only
integrated the
density of that
of the individual cell as we  have
the resolution 5 x 5 kilometers
here would be the expansion is
pretty sure that it wouldn't be difficult
to get data for that
for these cells you are mostly flat or
not and then you
have to expand the comfort function
accordingly but that's the case at the moment
we don't train either we don't have
things like that we separate when there is more
traffic that there is more
traffic jams and it
becomes less comfortable and so what these effects
could arise i
unfortunately we didn't
take these measures into account either
[music]
in the  When choosing the means of transport,
the time I need to arrive somewhere is also important to me,
priced in
terms of comfort  for example to say if it
doesn't take me that long it's
more comfortable
we know the route
profile of the people so every single person has
from this study
there are 15 categories whether so far or not so
far and which route
we know that could be better
integrated so  that has been
integrated so let's have a look at
it at the moment it has less of an impact than
would be nice, for example the
person with the furthest distance
uses the most drivers something that is
n't quite realistic now
we have to improve our satirical population
in that case too
addition, we don't
really consider which routes from a to b the
individual agents make, it's
really just about the number of routes
a certain longer that a person
makes because we're just not on the
level of detail we're modeling all of
germany currently step is
monthly
and  this choice can therefore be adjusted at most
once a month  en if
you wanted to take a closer look at a city
, then of course you would have to
go on a different scale, but
the model as it is already has
a million and a half agents and runs for
a few hours if you really walk away from
each one
wanted to install it would just
explode
how do you actually deal with the
accessibility factor i.e. people
who
just can’t walk far, for
example to public transport audi but definitely don’t
want to use a car themselves
aging society walking disabilities
such topics that a bit more than
comfort but that is  really i
can't participate
like that unfortunately not yet explicitly [music] interested in these technological changes like autonomous driving that i
send my car 20 530 off and the car
then drives yes but i'm not in it and i
say i just want my things
mine  auto do things that he was so what
also considered such leerfa  harden the
mobility types are just the
ones we have today and we didn't
add any other technologies because
you
would have to make strong assumptions for that. what do
people have for preferences about autonomous
driving, which doesn't even exist today, so there's
too much  can't find any data
that means
it's just not in the model as it is
now let's see what
else you can select
for the model
and
we have a whole list
of options that you can then use in group
work to  putting
together a scenario in the next step,
but so that you know what you are doing
, i will of course present them
first, we have a list of three
possible regulations, that means they are
political measures that can more
or less be closed as laws,
there we have the regulation
weight limit there then happens in the
model the assumption that
by a legal re  successful cars from
2017 will no longer be heavier we
see here on the
quad a few points data points we
see the car that is shown
here as a data point right up here so
that's kind of the direction it's
going the trend so if we do that  so
-called business-as-usual scenario, which
just
looks at all previous trends, then the
development here would be according to the trend
and if we choose these measures
, the development will simply be capped, that
may sound like a somewhat
unrealistic measure, but in principle
the eu is doing with its
ordinance for fleet limit values a very similar thing that not so many emissions per car are allowed to happen in total the second policy measure is bike-friendliness and there we have an example of these comfort curves our a
sumption is that in business as us
al the b
ke is more densely popul
ted  areas is much more
comfortable than in  not so populated areas
and through
infrastructure
measures, for example, it will then be greatly improved, especially in the cities, in the countryside
it may also improve a bit
because
electric bikes can then be used there
and charged better through
infrastructure expansion or
the third regulation also applies
again  mainly the city
centers it's about restrictions for
combustion engines that could be driving bans
that could be
loud
stories or something and there
we have the case that the business-as-
usual comfort curve is at the top and the
curve is then pushed down with the measure
that is  once the political measures
that we can choose there you can
afterwards in the group work choose
a maximum of two measures from each of these categories
just so that you don't
say let's click something different everything will be
for the best
as a second category we look at
investments so that's it  about that
the state takes money into its own hands and the
question that then has to be decided in the
group is where should this money go because
once we have the subsidization
of electric cars at this point
the model
has already been caught up a bit by reality, i.e. in
business  as usual, we have the
2016 subsidies in there and our
assumption is now the subsidy will
double per car and that
actually happened with the corona measures
secondly we have a
subsidy for public transport or
let's just assume that I'm responsible for the selection of
the  agents the price is halved
and that is then
factored into the agents’ decision via the cost
factor and the third option here
is a strong expansion of the electric
charging infrastructure
there in the business is the user case
it is assumed that the current trend
is that down here there is data again
that  the trend
levels off to 200,000 charging stations in 2035 and with
this option the lades  stations
that are then actually arranged in the model on the map
and that go into the
convenience of the electric
vehicles would then increase to a
million
as a third
category we have events these are
things that perhaps
politics don’t have a direct influence on
but of course we have to  if we
want to look into the future, others also
do about external developments and
how they behave, and then
you can also choose
business as usual, it just stays the way
the previous trend was, or we
assume that one or the other
event will occur
Firstly, there is a much steeper increase in
the price of petrol.
Of course, you can also see this
as a regulation if you want to, because
you can say yes, CO2 prices could be
introduced on fuels
for example,
the intermodal digitization is thought
probably the most complex measure
that we have in the model is the idea of
l technologies impro
ing the comfort of electric cars, for e
ample by si
ply finding charging stations in an
car sharing app, on the other hand, the
idea of an app showing me all cars
aring cars i can do everythi
g  use them together and
thirdly from public transport
and you can see that the increase
in rural areas is even higher
than in the city
behind this is the acceptance of, for
example, call taxi shuttle buses that can be used via digital offers. the
third
event is world market world market
growth  of electric
cars compared to the
trend is
increasing because the
number of cars bought is simply increasing and
one assumes that the prices
will also fall faster
and the weather event is an increased
car sharing offer since doubles
compared to business as usual so we
have  business as usual  here is this line
and it will then be steeper
simply a larger range of
carsharing cars then we can now go
into
the group work
our
online participants can
again in this 2 duo 2
all individually make a selection of
measures here in the room I will
ask you three groups  to form we have
a group table here one there and
one in the back with each group
one of us will be there to
help again if there are questions the groups
have the task within 20
minutes to
firstly think about what our goal
as a group is for  mobility 20 35 and then to take
a selection of these measures that
you think will best get you closer to this goal yes
please just spread out around
these three tables
we will continue when everyone has
returned to their seats so we
can here  see the selection of
the groups
we have the online group with the
vote and the three groups here in the
room  n we named after animals here
group adebar because there this
stork is hanging above us group bobby and group
knut not with c but with k
can now also tell us in this order
what their goal was what influenced their
choice of measures
who tells us that for
the  gruppe adebar yes so the objective
the measures first
looked through that that was also
presented and then the idea was we
have two options
the combustion engine does it not come off well it
is somehow about reducing
the criminal and now we had the
options either
replacing combustion engines with electric cars or reducing the number
of cars overall and
we
decided for various reasons that it
makes sense to reduce the number of cars overall because of a nice side effect
and we then
geared our measures to that
the bike-friendliness is
explained by  even so to say if
we au  to or or if we
want to change the attractiveness of the different modes of transport in relation to each other we
can either make the car less attractive
or the alternative means of transport
more attractive the bike-friendliness
is then the latter
we then had
another problem the first and third
regulations seem to work well in a double pack
the  the second starts somewhere
else we had to or or
we would like to opt for a
second regulation, which is
why we took the combustion engines in the
city
centers even if they
didn't reduce the number of cars overall
, so to speak, with the investments themselves the
principle of making alternative modes of transport
more attractive  ie to subsidize the remaining v
and then
the first and third investments
are again both counting on the electric car
we have now decided in favor of the
charging infrastructure here because we
also didn't tick it in the vest
assuming it will  that the subsidization
of electric cars will be unnecessary if the
electric car becomes cheaper overall
the events there it was more about
a kind of forecast, digitization
like all the other groups we
ticked them and
then we ticked the higher
price of petrol he hates and 24 based
on that secondly  because we have a hidden influence like
you introduced at the beginning
if
need be if it doesn't happen by itself you can
also artificially
re-enact taxes politically re-enact taxes yes then let's take a look at it a bit first
and now compare here if this is
stopped very quickly the
business as usual scenario, i.e. all
trends continue as usual with the
scenario that this group has
put together for the
number of mobility types used
, we then see a clear difference between
the
combustion engines and the
business  as usual very strong run  ter
and especially the rpnv catches that so
in this scenario the people
really switch in larger groups from the car
to the public transport
the foot and bicycle traffic is
actually a bit weaker than in
business as usual
the electromobility is much
better achieved but still the goal
of  these six million cars in
2030 do not see the emissions that result from this
we see here even in business as usual they
actually stayed the same
and in these with these measures they are
going down a bit
that unfortunately the eu will still
not be reached here and the  the trend is also
not quite as steep as that of the target
so firstly we started too late
and secondly it would have to be
a little faster
to be able to achieve such a target here we have
the electric vehicles in the year 2035 as an
example on the map there we see it  that
the map in this scenario
selected scenario looks significantly greener
, that is, the proportion of
el  electric vehicles is significantly higher
and especially in densely populated areas
there we have the ruhr area
and purely
in berlin it looks like it is
mainly the commuter belt around berlin
not the center itself
and then there are also a few spots in
munich stuttgart hamburg
So mainly in the big cities
, the proportion of electric vehicles
in this simulation is increasing,
oh it looks the same, the
system has somehow swallowed itself up,
so we can't look at the
content right now, but there are questions
or
there are wishes for something else to look at,
so we  could, for example, look at such a
map for public
transport because
it has increased significantly here
and for berlin yes
yes
exactly then we have so first
of all is the pnv really bad cover
apparently significantly larger the proportion
was actually on berlin  purely
because the question came up for berlin to
look at
there
we also have
the outer circle again around berlin
both with the electric cars you can of
course see it more precisely here
for the
emissions we even come
relatively close to the goal so berlin has the
peculiarity that public
transport is actually used more
than the combustion engines  in
all of Germany of course
looks different probably an advantage there is
a question
the percentage of there is shown at the
time
and we can
see it in comparison so it is not the increase that is
convincing but that would now be the
comparison of how much more we have on
in this scenario as in the
where that was already clearly visible with the with
the share
we have a question is that
how bicycle traffic is or how
can it be explained now one looks
as if it won't happen anymore  electric cars
will it looks like if the iv is not
increasing
in berlin what you see on the map is also
the mobility case gu  t can see
the car sharing is extreme in our simulation results
even increases so much the right
to public transport is somehow suppressed if
you now add something like
bergkönig to car sharing it
is perhaps not completely
unrealistic to the extent yes
I would see here now too  not
on it myself klaus but that's definitely
the effect of
seeing life in berlin for some
reason and then no other pieces and that also explains a bit
why the proportion of women here
probably doesn't increase that much overall
yes when we are  we don't have any further questions
maybe we'll take the next
scenario the bobby group bobby is the
gorilla who is sitting behind it that's where the
name comes from who tells us
what the objective for the bobby group was and
how it justified the exception measures selection
[music]
[  Music]
so a very short summary in
German bobby has set himself the goal of
the cars to reduce the number of cars
the measures are relatively similar
the differences can only be found here at
the point that the subsidization of
public transport was a goal of this group in order
to get people into public transport
and no electric goal was additionally
chosen and  with the increased
car sharing offer, this group
actually wants to ensure that people
can do without their own car
and then still
have a car available when they need
it. they also
discussed the higher price of petrol for a long time, but
for reasons  social
justice decided against it then let's take a look
at it in comparison and look at bobby
that looks
very similar
as far as the petrol engines are concerned and as far as local public transport is concerned
the foot and bicycle traffic also
looks similar we see a real
difference with the electric
cars here  in the scenario
adebar significantly above those in the scenario  o bobby
lie down for that the
car sharing is a bit higher at bobby than here so
what you would have expected
after these measures was the
emissions actually
look similar overall the group
but performs a bit better
bobby is a bit closer
to this one  line and the
composition is a little bit
different because
different so that's car sharing
also causes emissions the
electric vehicles are actually significantly less
in the
bobby scenario
so actually
less everywhere we only see red fields no
blue ones where there would be more in  one
cell and the share of carsharing
apparently still only sees it in
the
individual large cities not even
in
[music]
in the urban agglomeration because it is
really recognizable
with bobby but more
carsharing vehicles or more
carsharing use can be seen here in berlin
again  bit outside hamburg
se  oh dear, that's one of those places
we'd say we have to
take another look at where it comes from in the model,
as I said, it's a very
complex model in which you
sometimes
find out through discussions like this,
maybe something else could be funny
we have to find out.
there are questions or comments about this
comparison of the two scenarios. what
can be seen very well here is that it
is obviously easier for people
to switch from a combustion engine to an electric car than from a
combustion engine to no car, and that's why
emotions are lower in the adebar model
than in the  model bobby it
seems that people would rather continue
to
drive their electric car or rather not drive a
car so let me explain the
differences here yes in car sharing you would drive a
car you just would
n't own it anymore but maybe
it is  car sharing it is electric or
combustion engine that is calculated pro rata
according to the
dates di  e we had a stop and then with
a projection that the proportion of
electric cars there will of course also increase there was also a question or a ball of public transport look at the model what
happens then i don’t care the
difference it looks very similar
here that is  with beer a little
bit more there comes right up to
this line here it's a
little bit down so the overall
difference it's not that big
yes if we were there if we put the two
green cards next to each other
we probably wouldn't
see it at all  here we see that there are both
places where bobby more carsharing
sorry more pnv is available
namely
purely quiet
individual areas outside of berlin
and in the area otherwise but rather
a little less pnv compared
to the adebar scenario
then i would say let's watch the
knut  still to who can report
to us yes I do
the overview we have the table again
se  hen
with
ok yes exactly we are the knut group
we were the only ones who obviously decided in favor of
the weight
limit against the ban on the combustion engine in city centers because we thought that this weight limit measure would also have an effect in rural areas and would not just be limited to the metropolitan areas  would
that be the background for the investments
, we were primarily concerned with
not thinking it makes
sense to subsidize individual car ownership
from the general public, but
rather the charging infrastructure so that the
individual decision to have a car
also works  with the electric car
but still not even more the
number of cars accordingly also
goes down the events we have
simply evaluated according to the current
situation simply remember that the
price of petrol will rise and we think
that the future
can only work with lower emissions
if the digital  ization is also
organized there, the sharing is more
intelligently accompanied, for example, such
controls as when will the
king of the ball come to my place and can I expect that
within the next ten minutes
or not. These are simply
motors that then also support the use of
such alternative
connection options
and right now
a lot has to happen in rural areas too so that
what we wish for is just possible
thank you very much for the explanation because we
are really
only
precise here but it is already set the same way
so i also thought
let us all compare war with knut
because they  are the same
here are the same there and then we
will now go into the sensitivity analysis at this point, so to speak
, how
much does the result change if you
just move one parameter from here to there
if we look here again at the first one, like
the mobility selection
the
qualitative pattern is similar but we
you can see and quantitatively there is a
difference the
petrol diesels are going back but
with knut not as far back as it was
in the final and public
transport is not increasing so much the electric
cars are not increasing either and walking,
cycling and karl schön look
relatively similar
yes similar
[music]
wants to see a quantitative but not clearly qualitative difference in
the emissions the
choice with the weight limit
ensures that the trend here
is actually right
here while we still have a bit of a hump here
but we also see the problem there
started too late
to reduce emissions
now we have the electric cars here
they are less
pronounced but actually a group in the
same places it looks like so yes
the the difference map is not
not very clearly different in any places
we just see it
effect again that there are
less electric vehicles in total here  r
are there but the area distribution
looks similar and with the
proportion of combustion engines
we have there we basically see a
bit of the negative image of this we
have the electric vehicles here in all
these places where we don’t have them on this
map
that that bans  from the city centers there
is no tears in the scenario and
we see it the other way round
I wouldn't put that in the
city centers and the somehow rhine
ruhr area is there and also included
and now you have
more combustion engines because of
that you have it  just the advantage that you could
lower the version much better
than you basically had a quad
on you hadn’t
managed to get rid of so much less cars
overall, which you just continued
to accept the same amount of
car traffic
but due to the weight restriction
keep low one mission consumption
exactly  this is exactly the measure that
affects the inner cities  that wo
n't let the combustion engines into the cities
anymore
let's take a quick look at
the table what our online audience
has selected in a vote
, we are right
on track with the regulations and also with the
investments
that the adebar group  has chosen
in the events
, it is the digitization that everyone has
chosen and also the
world market growth of electric cars
that is maybe
we just have a
quick look at what kind of effects it has on
electromobility if we compare adebar and online
then we can then  see that the
selection of electric cars is clearly
increasing here in terms of mobility mobility times
overall on
the emission, it doesn't seem to have a major
effect
and the distribution on the map
is
n't that clearly
different either,
so at least there aren't any
particular points
that are particularly different overall
just a few more
j  a i think we have reached
the end of the event in terms of time
there are still
short comments questions about
the whole event
otherwise
we would like to thank you very much for being
here and participating and the
discussions we are always happy to take up the
points in the  groups to
be included in the considerations of how we can further improve
the model at the next
opportunity thank you very much
[applause]
[music]